this is why OIC can be a slippery
[Music]
slope hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to aby's Kitchen today I'm going
to be looking at the Tik Tok trend of
OIC users posting their what I in a day
and I'm going to be reviewing The Good
The Bad and The possibly super dangerous
we're going to go back to Old School
aby's kitchen review days so heads up
here I will be mentioning calories and
also very low calorie diets and if
you're not subscribed definitely hit
that subscribe button and check out my
description for my free Hunger crushing
combo ebook Okay so I have talked a lot
about OIC on my channel including
chronicling a real life Journey with my
friend and manager Ginger and aside from
the risk of abuse one of the main
physical health concerns that experts
have with OIC is the risk of actual
malnutrition nurition so glb1 agonists
work by suppressing appetite and
reducing the rate at which food exits
the stomach so that alone can result in
some significant weight loss but they
also can cause a lot of severe nausea
which can further reduce people's desire
to eat so the risk here is that folks
might end up being put on too aggressive
of a dose the drug may actually work too
well patients eat far too little they
lose weight way too fast including
metabolic muscle mass and they actually
become Mal nourished now we don't have a
lot of research on the likelihood of
malnutrition but the New York Times
recently reported on the concerns of
weight loss doctors that in some cases
the drug can take dieting way too far
ultimately weight loss always comes down
to a calorie deficit and while zic makes
staying in a calorie deficit a lot
easier because your hunger cues are
suppressed you still actually need to
make sure that you're meeting your basic
nutrition needs even if the cues are no
longer there there so safe effective
weight loss rates are generally around5
to 1% of body weight per week likely at
the higher end when on OIC but this
equates to around a 20% calorie deficit
give or take which is a safe cut to
prevent a good chunk of that weight
coming from lean body mass like muscle
or bone now this is what we recommend
with any non-pharma weight loss diet but
a lot of folks on OIC will push that
deficit much much further and that
explains means one stud's finding that
within a year of oepic treatment
participants lost almost as much lean
mass as they did Fat MK I spoke with a
number of my colleagues who work with
oepic patients plus Eric Williamson of
unlocked Fitness and Nutrition and most
said that they try not to go below 14 to
1500 calories while ultimately
prioritizing protein at every single
meal plus snacks re suggest that fat
loss can increase threefold when going
from 10 to 15% of calories from protein
to around 20 to 30% and the greater the
deficit the more protein that you're
going to need to stimulate muscle
synthesis so some of my colleagues
actually suggest that when calories get
very low their clients are aiming for
around 30 to 40% of calories from
protein so to put that into perspective
for you guys if you are consuming 1,400
calories on OIC you're aiming for 105 to
140 gram of protein per day spread out
in 20 35 G doses throughout the day to
maximize muscle preservation all that
said one of the nice things about OIC is
that you don't have to obsess about
calories anymore so I wouldn't recommend
counting and tracking everything you put
into your mouth but rather simply
focusing on hitting those protein goals
give or take complimenting that protein
with moderate portions of fiber carbs
and fat and letting your appetite guide
the rest on that note let's take a look
at some EX examples of what iena day on
OIC videos
[Music]
online okay first of all lemon water
does not boost your immune system just
want to get that out of the way but
second the protein shake is a really
great start but 130 calories or so for
breakfast with no fruits or veg is kind
kind of a missed opportunity to sneak in
extra fiber and antioxidants also in the
next few months I may or may not have a
better tasting recommendation for you
just
saying okay this meal looks super
balanced we got tons of protein in The
Omelette healthy fats and fiber in the
avocado and fiber carbs in the whole
grain toast that said she probably only
got around 15 g of protein just based on
how much she ate so to bump that up I
would consider doing my omelettes with
one to two whole eggs and the rest egg
[Music]
whites okay this looks so delicious and
I love that ozenc has helped her find a
way to enjoy rice in moderation I also
love that she did one roll with rice and
the other one with cucumber which helps
to contribute a little more antioxidants
and fiber that said without knowing
anything about this woman's metabolic
needs I would say this is likely too
aggressive of a cut to meet overall
nutrient needs which makes it really
really hard to meet your protein needs
because the calories were probably in
the neighborhood of like 1,00 were're
only able to get around 50 g of protein
team we ideally would want at least two
or even three times that amount so this
is where I would be cautiously working
with my doctor to adjust the dose to
ensure that we can reach that goldilock
spot where your appetite allows you to
achieve that 20 to 25% calorie deficit
while still being adequate enough to not
become malnourished okay moving on
here's what I eat in a day 107 lbs down
with PCOS so I start off my day every
day now
with these Mighty turmeric and no joke
Ginger from Trader Joe's of course a
Chobani complete 20 g of protein and
then I was feeling a little off
yesterday so I had half looks amazing I
mean I'm not sure what the purpose of
the spicy shots are for maybe for
digestion and or immune support I don't
know but regardless I love that we've
got some Fiber here and we've got a
solid 20 something dose of protein to
start the day I had some chicken te p
marala with spinach and rice 42 G Core
Power always this is my kind of meal
here I mean people think you can't have
rice if you have PCOS or insulin
resistance but no you just got to dress
up those naked carbs like she did with
protein fiber and fat now I'm not sure
if the protein shake was served with the
chicken masala but if she could space it
out a few hours and have it as a snack
it would increase the utilization of
that protein for muscle protein
synthesis since there's already like a
fully utilized load with the chicken and
then dinner was this delicious zucchini
and cotia chicken these jalapeno poppers
that my friend made that look like
mummies 10 out of 10 had my Stanley
snack
tray and enjoyed a few like I said
glasses of wine again amazing and
totally non-restrictive it seems like
this creator has found like her
goldilock dose where she can lose or
maintain her significant weight loss
while still meeting her nutrient needs
I'm estimating around 150 gram of
protein give or take depending on how
much she ate so I would not be
particularly worried about malnutrition
or muscle wasting with an oepic diet
like this and now I like really want a
mummy wrapped jalapeno popper okay
[Music]
next
okay looks good though would probably be
ideal to add some produce to this meal
to bump up the fiber but protein looks
great there's probably around 25 to 40
grams of protein depending on how much
collagen she added though FYI collagen
protein isn't the most bioavailable
protein since it's missing tryptophan
but thankfully the eggs and the turkey
bacon helped compensate for that so this
looks good hey that's pretty
[Music]
good another great example of a full
protein dose for muscle preservation
with around 30 gr of
[Music]
protein okay so we got 24 g of protein
plus some carbs and like a tiny tiny
tiny bit of EG but Pro tip if you like
these kind of microwave meals Chuck a
few big handfuls of spinach into a bowl
before you microwave just to get in some
extra fiber and
[Music]
micronutrients okay so I'm not sure how
these snacks are like spaced out in her
day but ideally we give at least 2 hours
between protein doses I'm going to call
them so like she could do the protein
water and the built bar as one meal and
the fake bar and the premier protein
shake as another that said even if you
don't it's not like that protein just
gets lost or immediately turns into fat
when you are still in a calorie deficit
I'm just talking optimal scenario
considering the risk of muscle loss on
OIC so yeah there's a lot of protein
here maybe 150 gr even but because
virtually all the foods are Ultra
processed protein snacks that protein is
kind of coming in at the expense of
basically everything else we're lacking
fiber there's virtually no healthy fats
and there's probably a lot of additives
sodium and artificial sweeteners which
may be totally fine in the short run but
probably not so easy on the gut long
term that said a lot of folks need to
lean on convenience Foods while on OIC
because when your appetite is so
suppressed you kind of lack the
inspiration to cook for yourself food
really does become just fuel for some
folks so feeding yourself just like a
bunch of protein shakes or bars rather
than cooking a whole food meal may
actually be a true Act of self-care so
like I said I would just try to meet her
where she is with a few little simple
tweaks like the spinach hack just to
sneak in some extra micronutrients and
fiber without adding a lot more worker
stress and on that note whether you're
on OIC or really any other weight loss
journey I do hope this serves as a good
reminder that less is not necessarily
more even if your hunger cues are
unnaturally low on o senic we still need
to make the effort to meet our nutrient
needs both our macros and our micros
plus other beneficial compounds like
fiber and probiotics and failing to do
so will likely cause way more harm than
good and that's all that I have for you
guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below and I will see you next
time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye